[موسيقى]
هنا في منطقه ابو ديس تقتل اسرائيل الارض
من خلال قتل تربتها
فتحت اقدم هؤلاء السكان تختبئ قنابل
موقوته تشكلت بفعل عصاره النفايات
والابخره والغازات الصادره عن هذا المكتب
النار هذه 20 سنه مولعه هاي
من كثر ما هي مولعه تطلع شوف كيف صارت
الجوره الكبيره هاي لان زباله انحرقت وخفت
الارض فوق شايف كيف مبينه
راحت للنار فيها بتاكل فيها شوي شوي
[موسيقى]
الاندعاسات التي تنبعث منها
الجراثيم التي تنمو نتيجه
لتواجد مواد مختلفه في هذه النفايات
الانبعاثات الغازيه ايضا هناك غازات سامه
كثيره تنبعث من نتيجه لتحلل هذه النفايات
عندك غاز الميثان عندك غاز اكسيد
النيتروجين عندك غاز الكبريتيد الهيدروجين
كلها غازات سامه وذات رائحه كريهه
الغرب
ريحتها قاتله والملعون
[موسيقى]